W
D DEATHS WILPPEAY  DR. CCEEWRSIL
ANTWERS.
GOODNG TO BOTH O
DR. CE
REDAHEOODWARD
P
OU UP WITH
SOME OF THE ATTENDEES.
LISTEN TO TH>> Reporter: WHY ARS
NOTEARING MASKS?
>> I HAVE ONE WITH ME.
IT'S MY PREROGAT
>> BUTHY NOT WEAR ONEO STAY
SAFE?
>> I HAVE A HARD TIME
UN PEOPLE WHEN THEY
LKON'T WEA
>> BUT YOU CAN HEAR ME RIGHT
NOW?
>> I CAN HEAR YOU.
>> SIR, PLEASE TELL ME.
WHY ARE YOUEARING A MASK?>> BEC.
IT'S A FAKE PANDEMIC CREATED TO
DESTROY THE UNITED STATES OF AM
>> BUT THE PRESIDENT TO BOB
WOODWARD THAT THERES VIRUS,
TH IT IS
DEADLY.
>> THA OPINION.
THE CDC SAID ONLY PEOPLE
DIE FROM COVID.
THE OTHER 2,000AVE
--
>> I'M NOTD.
THE GOODE., I DIE.
>> EVERY DAY.
>> WE GOTOUNTRY
MOVING
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
DO WEAR MASKS AND STAYUS?Y.TOOU
PEOPLE, YOUR FELLOWOOD.F SUPPOS
IT.
SO THIS IS -- IT'S -- IT'S ACTL
SIR, THE
PRESIDENT AND MBE TESIDENT COULH
EP.
YEAH, THINKE.N THE
WOODWARD QUITE Y, IS SURPRISING
KNEWLLHI TRIED WARNING PE
TRIEDTHIS, THE
PR T
HAS LARGER INHO
GSIT THROUGH CRISITHIS, BT THE
SAME TIME THA TLI H THIS
ONCERNING IT PUBLIC N' NMASK,
N' TO HLT
THE LONG-TERMAC WHAT YOU
HELIHT -- HTHERY LITTLE TRUST I
AND PUBLIC HEOMPLISTS
OFHI SET IN FEBRUYND
MARCH WHEN RATED AND RAY OF THI
VIRUS AND UNDER PU EXPERTISE THM
YOU, BUT I WONDEIFT -- OUT OF A
L AWHAT?NG. AND WE KEEP
MO BEENED THE
MARCH AND I B LIKE THESEHOON'T
>> YEAH, MEAN, REALLY
HA IN NEW RK AHEURGE.
I WAS ON THERO LINES.
I PEOPL D
D P CBOUT HOW THIS A HOAX OR S .
AND TH IN MANY OTHERROUND TH C
IT WILL CONTINU I COMMUNIES HAVN
ES THE INAT IS F M
IT DAILY BASIS.THAT I
KIRSTEN, IT INFURIATING WHE
CROWD, ALLFEOE IRERND
>> OUR COUNTRY IS DOING T.
HAD T PAUSE TO GET
CNA GOT RID OGETTING RID AROUN.
WE'RE COMINGROUND.  NEXT
YEAR BETTER TH LAST YEET
>> HE'SNG
VIRUS, HE'S PRETDIEMIC IER
>> YH.I D THIS -- IT'S REALLY
-- A TRAGEDY ON SO MANYUT PCUSA
BEEV
MEAN, IT'S -- WHENHE ALL
OF THIS THE WDWOOK TT
HET BSE CANIM SAYING IT.
IT'S -- IT'S A RECOR STILL HAV
NO BIG DEAL ANIDN'T
HAPPEN. WAS TERESTING LISTENING
MAN WHO SAID THE GOOD LORD IS I
TO GO WE OF THIS
FROM VARIOUS TRU SERS.
AND YET WHEN THE CARMING, ALLEG
RDOTECT COMING, THE GOOD  NOT G
THEM.NONE OF ILIKE, THE THINGS
CHOOSE TE OF AND THAT
DONALD TRUMP THEM ABOUT
-- A T
THINGS THAT THEY NEE BE
WORRIED AB AND THEY'RE
IN THIS PANIC AND THEN YOU HAVE
DON' TO CAUSE
THAT'S ETI A DOES
AS IS TT